so when we analyzed it in second law
applied to this compound system we had
two equations for M one object one and
object two and what we found is that we
had three unknowns the tension in the
string and the accelerations of the two
objects now how do we how do we solve
this system well we're missing one
condition which is a constraint
condition which is as object two moves
in object one moves they have to move in
some relationship together and now what
we'd like to do is show an analytic
approach for finding that constraint
condition and well the way we think
about it is that we'll call L equal to
the length of the string and this
quantity is a constant and what we'd
like to do is introduce coordinate
functions for our object one and our
object 2 and Express L in terms of those
coordinate functions and then take two
derivatives of L set that equal to zero
because it's a constant and that will
give us a relationship between the
accelerations of objects 1 & 2 now this
is a little bit tricky and so what we
want to do is very carefully show how we
introduce coordinate functions recall
that we had J hat 1 down and J had two
downwards what that implies is that
we're choosing some origin and we're
let's choose an origin up here and for a
coordinate function for object 1 it has
to be consistent with our choice of what
we mean by J hat 1
so in this Ken's sense y1 is a positive
quantity when we're going downward
now what about coordinate functions for
the other objects in the system well
let's look at a few things first this is
a fixed distance we'll call it s1
between the center of the pulley and
between the ceiling and the center of
the pulley and let's make each of the
pulleys a radius R and let's call this a
function y be
and let's make this y2 of T so now we
have coordinate functions for two and
coordinate functions for one and again
recall that this distance here s 2 is a
fixed distance and when we define these
coordinate functions in this fashion we
know that the second derivative d
squared y 1 dt squared this is precisely
what we mean by the acceleration of
object 1 and in the similar fashion d
squared y 2 dt squared is what we mean
by the acceleration of object 2
so we've introduced a coordinate system
we've made it very clear what we mean by
the accelerations of a 1 and a 2 and now
let's look at our constraint condition
that the length of the string is
constant so what we're going to do is
try to see if we can express the length
of this string in terms of all the
coordinate functions and some of these
ancillary quantities so what we have
here is that the length of the string is
YB going down here so the length of the
string has a factor YB it wraps around
pulley B so that's PI R and it goes up
to this length here now this length is
YB minus s1 so that's why B minus s1 we
wrap around the pulley again that's PI R
and now we have this length here which
is y1 minus s1 now s1 ya and let's just
make sure we have all of our quantities
here now we also have another constraint
condition that this length of the string
call this we're going to call this l1 we
have a second string here
- and l2 is given by Y to this length is
y2 minus YB and that was what we called
this constant s2 so we now have two
string lengths l2 equals y2 minus YB and
both of these string lengths are
constant and we have the following facts
let's start with this one first
that the second derivative of L to DT
squared because length of the string is
a constant that's zero and that tells us
two derivatives of this is a two and two
derivatives of that is a B and this is
something that we saw before that block
B and two are moving together
so when we treated the system is just
being two together we see that the
acceleration of two and the acceleration
of pulley B are the same so we could
have just said that before we begin now
let's put these equations aside for the
moment and now let's consider taking two
derivatives of length of string 1 recall
string 1 is this object here we'll call
this string 1 and this string 2 now
again if we take two derivatives let's
look at our expression first we see that
we have two factors of Y B and we have a
bunch of constants whose derivative is 0
so we don't have to worry about the
wraparound distances the PI RS we don't
have to worry about the constants s 1
all we have to think about is which
quantities are changing in time so we
have to a B when we take two derivatives
and we have one factor of a1 and that's
zero and now because the block and 2 and
pulley B are accelerating together we
have our condition which is 2
a 2 plus a 1 is 0 or that a 1 is equal
to minus 2 a 2 and that is the extra
constraint condition that will enabled
us to solve the system of equations